John: Good morning Hank, It's Tuesday.
So on Friday, Rosianna and I left the magic
and awesome of NerdCon: Stories to head up
to Princeton, Minnesota, where I raced cars
on a dirt track against best-selling author
and all around awesome person Maggie Stiefvater.
So Hank, an IndyCar driver I know once told
me that in racing the only thing more dangerous
than being too aggressive is being too cautious.
Which is an observation that I think applies
to more than just racing, and while I'm certainly
an uncommonly anxious person, I don't think
of myself as an overly cautious one.
So I was feeling kinda excited as we arrived
at the Princeton Speedway.
I mean at no point did I actually think I
could win the race but I did think I could,
like, finish it without being pulled out of
a burning vehicle which as it turned out was
overly optimistic.
Took my first ever ride in a four-wheeler
to my race car which belonged to a 17-year-old,
hence its number.
My coach for the evening was his dad, Alan.
And special shoutout to Alan's kids, my pit
crew, ten year old Allison and eight year
old Aaron.
My first lesson was getting in and out of
the car, which as you can see is ridiculously
difficult.
Hank, I need to linger on this shot for a
moment because I want you to understand how
hard it is to get out of these cars even when
they are not on fire.
Also, I want you to notice my excellent Eleanor
and Park t-shirt, which I got at dftba.com.
So Alan's an experienced race car driver and
an excellent coach.
Alan: You don't want to jump up on the throttle...
John: He explained to me at least a dozen
times that coming out of the corner, I would
feel an urge to over-correct the steering
and/or let off the throttle and that giving
into that urge would be a significant mistake
and I was able to remember that advice for,
like, five-and-a-half laps of actual racing.
Put on my smoking hot fire suit, my helmet,
a pair of gloves, and then Maggie showed up
with her awesome car with its awesome license
plate.
And then after an impossibly beautiful sunset
came to Princeton, I belted myself in for
our first of three scheduled races.
Maggie jumped out to a lead, and she was faster
than me and also a much better driver, but
my car turned really well in the dirt and
its power was exciting and intoxicating and
I was just trying to keep up with her but
then I thought, "You know, maybe I could drive
alongside of her and really make a race out
of this."
And then on the fifth lap coming out of turn
four, I felt an urge to correct the steering
and yeah...
The speedway staff got to me very quickly
and although I could feel the heat of the
fire in my back and legs, they kept me calm
and pulled me out and I was fine, but I'm
not going to lie, Hank, it was terrifying.
But then they fixed the problem with the car
and for some reason, I decided to get back
in it.
In fact, I won the second heat - more precisely,
Maggie let me win - and I got a trophy and
everything and then we raced for a third time
and Maggie dominated me so thoroughly that
the regular pro-drivers at the speedway asked
to take her on and she beat them as well!
So Maggie won the race, but I caught fire
and didn't get hurt, which felt very much
like, you know, some kind of winning.
And late that night as I tried to sleep, I
kept playing the race back in my mind: me
doing precisely the thing I'd been told not
to, the heat of the flames against my back,
my panicked hands as I tried to unbuckle the
belts, the smoky relief of being pulled from
the car.
There are of course smart risks.
The proper line to run through life is somewhere
between extreme caution and extreme aggression,
but this wasn't one of them.
That said, Hank, I have to confess that I
am proud to have lost to Maggie, but not to
myself.
But in the end, Hank, I think I'm going to
use this occasion to announce my retirement
from race car driving.
I'm headed back to the grandstands where I
belong.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.